hello and welcome to zero hi pooja I
gather we only recently played him and
quite remember what that was I think it
was a white again so he declines the
banker with me six so very respectable
line of course i don't i have not yet
studied this i have to say i'm just
playing it by m and this might not be
the way to do it yeah here he has open
job or given me the b5 square which can
sometimes be used for the night this is
an idea that I had seen so going for it
quite interesting it is these nights
here don't quite know what to make of it
I mean I know that this is a fairly
standard setup it's nothing totally
unusual for this opening but I don't
quite know how to evaluate the situation
here I mean it's clear that if i can
trade a little bit here that favors me
considerably but i'm not sure if it
happens okay so here definitely we have
some trades mmm yeah c4d three yeah I
think c4 makes a bit more sense okay is
he coming with you five he really is
I one day a v6 is a movie actually just
pre-empting the pushes takes Bishop
takes f5 I could take this and yeah
maybe I need some counter play I think
and I don't think I'll get it if I just
put the knight on d4 or something like
that I have to say this line it's pretty
clear i also got got this when I was
playing Peter Svidler in a recent been
to blitz and my position after like
moved 12 to 15 was actually very good
but um but um as I didn't like it all
that much interesting a just pushes
forward
hmm it is surprising
I thought having f6 as an option an
additional option would be quite helpful
for Wyatt but he doesn't seem to view at
them like that ok anyway how do I come
how do I defend here still fairly
dangerous of course I would like to get
d5 and I would like to get some how get
stuff developed
rebs so still very very problematic this
pollution he has fairly easy attacking
moves okay I tried to play 94 and
potentially Bishop f5 here okay just a
text this
not happy about it but I can take your
five now right
I don't think that this isn't that bad
anymore actually 94 maybe I can still
take this
maybe just something like this the time
is somewhat sword low
so not easy to play
yeah crude for dangerous absolutely h5
time morning and it's very dangerous
actually
now I don't see a defense to that that's
it's super dangerous I don't expect
moose don't expect his mercy at all I
just thought Bishop h6 that was strong
it makes it sometimes all the more
difficult yeah if they play all kinds of
unexpected moves I have no time i
blundered bishop 26 m
I know we can take but trying to get
some kind of play here I have 20 seconds
and i will lose on time I just got to
print the aid or something and I know
check my twin check
no maybe not if it doesn't have a direct
wind i have stuffed myself look H 492
check
you
thread and Queen h2 here check check
check check mmm you will be known Tony
Jack position is snowed Rome check check
check check check check draw offered
check back for fixed on town I was just
pressing because of the possible
threefold okay yeah it's tough to give a
evaluation about this you played down
this is well up to this point where he
had a strong attack and it's it's very
difficult to defend this position here
with black white has such active pieces
yeah okay blundered d5 and now a
situation is it's still very dangerous
it's still very dangerous am Bishop
before I have a stronger arm played this
yeah this is I have stronger moves here
94 we should be form the thing is that I
this is this is now getting extremely
dangerous with the age porn I mean no
matter what the engine says I'm
the engine just says I'm winning this
position here but this is not in a real
game here with no time h4 h5 is
extremely scary yeah I didn't see your
defense and now just h5 is strong and
now Bishop h6 is normal instead he
played disc which is completely useless
and now the positioning becomes some
unclear again I'm Bishop g4 would have
been good just stopping stuff but ok i
just had to play moves i only have 30
seconds yeah yeah I'm losing of course
but you check check after that I mean
things are not at all clear and here
it's checkmate with 93 maybe I could
have done that in this time check that's
pretty easy actually because it cannot
take with rooke and I had second soon ok
but the check is very tempting and Josh
I check Charlie always just the
perpetual but of course I mean he can a
queen Iran is made in three yeah I mean
check its its users it's useless to
argue here it's it's made multiple times
and so on but I have two seconds left um
yeah I got into trouble here it's just
difficult to handle this position after
f5 really difficult yeah anyway thanks
for watching